[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a chinese action film called
iron protector spoilers ahead watch out
hence take
[Music]
care a martial arts expert named wu lin
is the successor of an ancient chinese
clan the iron feed he has come to a big
city for the first time in years
suddenly a group of gangsters in pursuit
bumps into a kid and drops his ice cream
to help him mulin goes looking for the
men and meets them in an alleyway they
have found the person they were chasing
and are about to kill him with the
excuse of getting the ice cream money
back wulin stalls them for a while but
when they start getting aggressive he
doesn't hold back he takes on a dozen
gangsters on his own showcasing great
kung fu skills by the end of the fight
he is the only one standing the man
whose life he saved is a wealthy
businessman named jia shan he offers him
money but wulin refuses to accept it he
then goes back to the child and gives
him another cone of ice cream suddenly
many cars surround him from all sides
the leader of the opposite group comes
out and hugs wulan revealing that the
two are good friends he is a kung fu
master and the owner of a security firm
jiang li wu lin and jiang li used to be
disciples of the same master they grew
up and trained together before jiang li
moved to the city to better his life he
has earned a lot of money and fame over
the years but has forgotten his master's
principles along the way as they talk we
find out that jiang li didn't leave the
village on his own he made a huge
mistake during a practice and was kicked
out by his master the master believed he
was not worthy of being taught a sacred
art like kung fu back in the present
wulin brings out the master's ashes
revealing that he passed away jang lee
breaks down crying still filled with
love for his mentor the next day they go
to jiang li's training center while
going through the security checkup wulin
is asked to remove his shoes because
they are made of metal jiang li knows
the history behind them so he allows him
to come in without taking them off the
business man jia shan has come to jiang
li to hire a bodyguard for his daughter
jiang li shows him the strength of his
men but joshua shows interest in hiring
wu lin wulin agrees to do it since one
of the master's teachings said the
protector will do anything in his power
to protect the employer the next morning
wulin meets jiashan's spoiled daughter
feifei the first meeting doesn't go as
expected as a startled fei-fei drops her
towel assuming he is an intruder after
finding out he is her new bodyguard she
offers him money to leave her alone
however wulin is true to his principles
so a little amount of money won't change
his decision as a last resort
faith threatens him with a fake gun but
wulin doesn't react at all later that
day the two drive to the mall feife
reluctantly walks around while he
follows her everywhere then she notices
a group of perverts bothering a girl she
confidently walks to the leader of the
group pulls a will smith and slaps him
in the face when the man is agitated she
lies that woolen asked her to do so the
thugs are about to beat up wulan when he
claims that he doesn't know who fey faye
even is the plan bites her back when
they believe him and start chasing her
to teach her a lesson woolen watches an
amusement as they make her run around
the mall but at last he decides to help
her and makes the thugs apologize at
night wulin dreams of his father
throwing him off of a cliff it turns out
he has had the same experience in real
life as well when he was only 7 years
old his corrupt businessman father tried
to kill him the reason is still unknown
to wu lin but he remembers his father
said success requires sacrifice before
throwing him off of a cliff then we are
introduced to a gangster named mr fu he
used to be jiashan's employer but is now
actively trying to kill him jiashan has
information about every criminal
activity foo has ever been a part of
hence the gangster wants him dead as
soon as possible a trusted fortune
teller claims that foo's end is near
although the man has been working for
foo for several decades he shoots him
dead because of the outrageous
assumption the next day wulin and
fei-fei go to a fancy restaurant fei
faye enjoys the meal while woolen stands
by her and keeps watch on everyone
suddenly he holds a waitress down
claiming that she is trying to harm
fei-fei an angered fey-fay rushes to the
bathroom but wulin barges in and
forcefully brings her outside on their
way back home they get into an
altercation again a bunch of men come to
fey faye's aid assuming that wulin is
harassing her she takes the opportunity
to run away but is then abducted by the
waitress and waiter from earlier wulin's
intuition is proven correct but he has
no time to celebrate he quickly follows
the car and gets on top of it after
jumping off of an overpass however he
soon loses his grip and falls down the
second time he doesn't bother jumping on
it but faces it head on after stopping
it and fighting the masked kidnapper he
manages to run away with feyfae when
they reach home feife asks him how he
knew the waiter and waitress were one of
the abductors wu lin replies that he has
trained himself to learn body language a
person can lie but their movement shows
how nervous excited or angry they are
feyfay also reveals that she has had
several bodyguards growing up she never
had privacy and the freedom to do things
as she liked hence she started to hate
all the bodyguards in general in the end
she adds that woolen is not as bad as
the other ones before going to bed feife
looks at her family photo and cries over
her late mother's memory somewhere else
the gangster foo sends his right hand
man to jiang li the man wants jang li to
help them kil ji oshan although jiang li
is skeptical he agrees to help them it
turns out that when he first came to the
city mr fu gave him a meal and helped
him start the business in turn the
gangster uses the trained bodyguards for
his own good but jiang li feels too
indebted to retaliate the next day
jiangli and wulan meet at a construction
site jiang li boasts about his knowledge
of the real world that wu lin has no
idea about he thinks he is better than
wulin because he has connections with
whom he maintains good relationships on
being asked to stop protecting fei-fei
wulan refuses for the first time in
their lives the brothers stand against
each other jangly reveals that he is
still bitter that wu lin got the special
boots and not him master always favored
wulin and thought he was a born fighter
now that they have a chance he wants to
test who out of them is better they get
into a fistfight but no one overpowers
the other since they match in strength a
magic fist technique has always been
jangly's specialty using it he punches
wu lin on his chest and slams him to the
wall in the end jiang li declares they
are no longer brothers and walks away
following the encounter wulin takes
fei-fei to a secluded house by a beach
they spend their days practicing kung fu
together wu lin reveals that the boots
he wears are 25 kilos each he has been
wearing them for the past 8 years in an
attempt to master a technique called the
108 kicks when he takes the boots off he
will be stronger than ever wu lin has
been watching dragon ball z then one day
jangly's people find out wulin and
fei-fei's location but zhang li knows
that his trainees are not even close to
wulin's expertise he gives them large
handcuffs to use in their favor during
the fight they attack at night when wu
lin is least expecting it the couple
runs into the woods where wu lin is busy
fighting the intruders taking the
opportunity two of the gangsters kidnap
feyfay and bring her to a warehouse
wulin follows them but accidentally sets
foot in a trap with a handcuffed tied to
his already heavy leg he has a hard time
fighting them still he knocks out
several men and gives them a difficult
competition in the end they trap both of
his legs and slam him into a wall when
he is weak a man drags him to a field
nearby jang lee sees his former brother
on the verge of death and feels a hint
of pain but he suppresses it with anger
he approaches wu lin and kills him with
a final punch to his chest they bury him
in a pit before returning to their base
the rain keeps pouring heavily turning
the pit into a puddle suddenly wulin
crawls out of it revealing that he is
still alive he was born with a heart on
the right side of his chest so the punch
didn't do him much harm with renewed
motivation woolen returns home and takes
off the metal boots it causes him to
master the 108 kicks technique then he
changes his appearance and wears a suit
before going to jiang lee's training
center hundreds of his trainees who are
guarding the place attack him but now
with 50 kilograms of weight off of his
feet wulin is undefeatable he only uses
his hands for defense and knocks several
of them out with his amazing footwork in
the end he is the only one standing in
the ring following the encounter he
confidently enters a room with mr fu
jiang li fei-fei and jiashan fu asks him
if he is not afraid to die to which wu
lin replies that success requires
sacrifice foo is shocked because he had
said the same thing to his son before
killing him several years ago phu and
jiashan worked together as partners but
one time fu made jioshan get caught by
the police which in turn caused the
death of his wife ever since then
jiashan has been looking to take revenge
on foo foo loved his son wulin dearly
until one day he witnessed wulin chasing
an animal away just by staring at it
foo's trusted fortune teller told him
that his son would be the end of him and
his career that was the reason why he
tried to kill wu lin even though he was
just a kid foo laughs at his fate
thinking that the fortune teller was
right all along he fires at wulin but
this time jiang lee stops him he is
tired of being a pawn in foosa legal
activities he claims that he wants to
fight wulin and give him a chance to
showcase the power of the 108 kicks they
get into yet another battle where jiang
li has an upper hand because of the
strength magnifying gloves he is wearing
as the fight proceeds wulan slowly
starts to overpower him but when jiang
li is about to be defeated fu shoots him
dead with his final breath he asks wulin
to live on and maintain the legacy of
the iron feet clan now only wulin and
phu are the ones left alive seeing his
death right in front of him foo tries to
make amends with wulan but his attempt
fails wulin launches at him ready to end
his life but decides otherwise he is
always fought fairly and killing the
opponent is against the master's rule he
doesn't want to swoop down to fu's level
so he lets him be with his ruined
business in the last scene we see wulin
spreading jangly's ashes in the air the
moral of the story today is that fortune
tellers are full of [ __ ]
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching